[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 22 septembre
vous regardez le 7 8 le journal merci de
nous retrouver pour cette nouvelle
édition commence tout de suite avec les
titres
maires et présidents de départements
sont en colère et le font savoir hier
ils manifester devant l'assemblée
nationale afin d'alerter l'état sur les
baisses des dotations et les
associations sont leur rentrée à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines elles étaient réunis
aujourd'hui pour présenter leurs
activités aux étudiants et enfin nous
reviendrons sur la cinquième édition des
victoires du paysage le concours après
mission de promouvoir l'aménagement
paysager contemporain et de valoriser
les métiers du paysage reportage à magny
les hameaux et à guyancourt
et la grogne des maires hier un grand
rassemblement des présidents et des des
départements et des élus s'est déroulée
à paris devant l'assemblée nationale le
but de cette manifestation était
d'alerter le gouvernement sur les coupes
drastiques dans leurs budgets due à la
baisse des dotations les précisions avec
haussmann vendeurs des
stops à l'asphyxient des départements
c'était le message hier des 400 élus
réunis devant l'assemblée nationale face
aux baisses drastiques des dotations de
l'état une baisse qui concerne aussi le
département des yvelines à hauteur de
288 millions d'euros
ce sont des sommes absolument
considérable que l'état ne nous donne
plus
alors que il décide de nos dépenses les
dépenses sociales et ils ne compensent
pas alors que normalement il a cette
obligation constitutionnelle pour le
seul département des yvelines sur un
budget d'un milliard d'euros c'est plus
de 280 millions d'euros que les
partenaires nous doit chaque année donc
vous imaginez bien que nous sommes
obligés de baisser le service aux
yvelinois et d'augmenter la fiscalité ce
qui est doublement insupportable et
assez durs pour les yvelinois ces
couples ont des conséquences sur les
dépenses sociales comme le rsa l'apa
pour les personnes âgées ou encore
l'éducation c'est un média important
fonctionnement 125 millions d'euros par
an on ne peut pas le diminuer il faut
bien que les élèves et ce qu'il faut à
la rentrée on compte qu'on continue à
entretenir nos collèges qu'on puisse
aussi équipé en informatique voilà donc
fouillé tout et que tout un plan à la
fois l'investissement fonctionnement
donc cette baisse nous en nous nous a
fait prendre des décisions qui sont qui
ont des lourdes répercussions sur les
yvelinois et c'est pour dire ça suffit
aucun représentant du gouvernement l'a
souhaité réagir sur cette mobilisation
mais les élus ne perdent pas espoir ils
tenteront à nouveau de se faire entendre
lors du congrès des départements à
poitiers du 5 au 7 octobre
et l'art aussi à bala le meurtrier du
couple de policiers de magnanville
rappelez vous c'était le 13 juin dernier
pourrait être inhumé dans la commune
yvelinoise de mantes la jolie où les
résidait avec ses parents la question
était transmise au conseil d'état
aujourd'hui jeudi 22 septembre par le
tribunal administratif de versailles le
maire michel vialay les républicains s'y
opposent il fait valoir un risque de
trouble à l'ordre public et craint de
voir la sépulture du terroriste âgé de
25 ans transformé en un lieu de
pèlerinage une perspective qui suscite
également des réticences au sein même de
la communauté musulmane la grande
mosquée de mantes la jolie refusant par
exemple d'organiser la prière funéraire
le préfet des yvelines aura le dernier
mot sur cette affaire et nous sommes
presque à la fin du mois de septembre
pourtant certains font encore leur
rentrée les associations de l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
par exemple une trentaine d'entre elles
étaient installées aujourd'hui à côté de
la maison de l'étudiant pour présenter
leurs activités et tenter d'attirer les
curieux petit tour d'horizon signé
nicolas kirillovitch
sabre laser zumba ou encore tombola les
dix-huit mille étudiants de l'université
de versailles saint quentin avait
l'occasion de se divertir pour la
rentrée des associations la possibilité
pour eux également de découvrir sous le
soleil les événements et animations
prévues pour l'année universitaire
aujourd'hui nous avons 32 associations
qui ont leur agrément à l'université ça
va des associations de théâtre d ation
de musique des associations de la
solidarité de l'environnement sur la
nature voilà il ya vraiment de tout tout
est très diversifiée et ils sont très
actives
installé à proximité de la nouvelle
maison de l'étudiant les responsables
des associations répondent aux questions
propose des activités et tente d'attirer
les plus jeunes parfois intimidés il
faut quand même avec les étudiants
trouver une petite accroche pour leur
donner envie de deux dossiers intéressés
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a plusieurs
petits outils d'animation qui nous
permette de voilà de faire la croche qui
viennent nous voir par curiosité au
début et puis ensuite
ensuite ils vont finalement s'intéresser
et poser des questions mais c'est vrai
que de même c'est quelque chose dont ils
n'ont pas forcément l'habitude des
bombes à voile à savoir exactement ce
qu'ils peuvent y trouver la rentrée des
associations de l'ue vs qu se poursuit
le mardi 27 septembre avec un rendez
vous cette fois ci sur le campus de
versailles
et on parle environnement à présent et
plus précisément des victoires du
paysage je vous disais en titre ce
concours vise à sensibiliser sur
l'importance du végétal et du paysage
dans la ville pour la cinquième édition
24 sites de la région ile-de-france sont
sélectionnés parmi eux certains sont à
magny les hameaux et à guyancourt
corinne salins les a visités avec le
jury du concours regarder
créer des ouvrages paysager qui
s'intègre au site et permettre
valorisation des ressources et réduction
de la consommation d'eau tel était
l'objectif du chantier des jardins
clairière de guyancourt l'un des 24
aménagements d'île de france
sélectionnés pour la deuxième phase du
concours des victoires du paysage
derrière moi donc il ya les jardins
filtrants en fait qui permettent donc de
traiter des eaux polluées avec
l'utilisation de végétaux ça a permis de
réduire de 60% du coup la consommation
d'eau potable du site donc ça équivaut
quand même à peu près à 12 piscine
olympique autres sites sélectionnés à
magny les hameaux les berges nord du
bassin du buisson était totalement
réaménagé platelage 100% chaîne de
normandie ont remplacé les talus et
sentiers boueux le but de l'opération
était de rendre totalement accessible de
les pontons et les berges du bassin des
cuissons qui était dans un piteux état
quand on est arrivé et donc on a rendu
accessible à peu près 130 mètres
linéaires de de platelage y compris un
bon taux spécifiques pour les pmr les
personnes à mobilité réduite pour cette
deuxième étape du concours les membres
du jury ont effectué des visites
techniques des différents aménagements
afin d'examiner qualité et originalité
des projets au delà de l'accessibilité
au delà de des matériaux locaux des
plantes indigènes
l'aspect esthétique avec ses terrasses
en bois avec ses platelage ces petits
pour ton et c est très intéressant dans
ce cadre naturel la soirée de remise des
prix aura lieu le 8 décembre le public
peut également voter dès maintenant sur
le site internet pour soutenir son
projet préféré depuis 2014 le nombre de
candidatures a augmenté de près de 30%
et demain vendredi à 23 septembre ce
sera le dernier jour pour la semaine de
la mobilité à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis le 15 septembre l'agglomération a
lancé de nombreuses animations et
enquête sur les déplacements dans le
territoire pour les particuliers mais
également pour les entreprises au sein
de la société thales un forum de la
mobilité a été mise en place dans les
locaux c'était hier une manière de venir
à la rencontre des usagers et de
répondre à leurs interrogations
camille lambert pour ce reportage
un forum de la mobilité pour venir à la
rencontre des usagers des transports en
commun à thales le 21 septembre
plusieurs stands d'information ont été
installés dans les locaux objectif
associer le personnel de l'entreprise
pour améliorer le réseau de saint
quentin en yvelines ça leur permet
d'avoir vraiment une relation de
proximité
d'avoir vraiment l'impression en tant
qu'utilisateur que les sociétés de
transport sont à leur écoute et vraiment
hip hop discuté un moment au calme dans
un élément convivial de leurs besoins
trois partenaires ski bus pour tous les
skis sont venus présenter leur ligne
leur projet avec ce forum thales espère
favoriser l'utilisation des transports
en commun auprès de ses 3000
collaborateurs
j'ai pas eu d'usagé nerfs donc justement
je me dis peut-être que ça devrait être
l'occasion de s'y mettre j'emprunte
souvent les les transports en commun
donc la ligne 15 et puis ça tombe bien
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et présentent
donc c'est pour leur faire part
d'éventuelles suggestions également me
renseigner au niveau des horaires une
initiative menée dans le cadre de la
semaine de la mobilité à saint quentin
en yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération a également mis en place
une enquête en ligne pour restructurer
son réseau de bus tous les habitants des
douze communes du territoire sont
invités à y répondre jusqu'au 15 octobre
innovation à présent la technologie 3d
ne cesse d'avancer mardi 20 septembre
dassault systèmes et la start up extrait
ont présenté à vélizy un pavillon
entièrement imprimé en trois dimensions
un bâtiment plus économe plus rapide à
concevoir mais aussi plus flexibles dans
sa réalisation c'est une première en
europe nicolas kirillovitch était à la
présentation de ce bâtiment du futur
regarder
une forme inspirée de la nature est une
structure en forme de grains de café
voilà à quoi ressemble le premier
bâtiment imprimé en 3d en europe une
prouesse technique et d'innovation
imaginé par la start up extrait le
pavillon de 18 mètres carrés a été
imprimé en moins de 24 heures plus tôt
que de couler du béton dans des moules
comme on le fait habituellement on vient
imprimée du béton des couches une coche
au-dessus de l'autre exactement ce qu'on
voit ici vous voyez sur le côté avec
l'aspect un petit peu des couches il ya
une partie qui est enduite voilà pour
des questions d'aspect et on a laissé à
nu une partie avec avec les couches si
la fabrication 3d est déjà utilisée
depuis plusieurs années dans l'industrie
son exploitation à grande échelle reste
marginal c'est justement l'objet de
cette première exposer les avantages et
les avancées induit par l'impression 3d
dans le futur l'objectif c'est d'emmener
le robot là où on doit construire il va
construire probablement et des matériaux
locaux et ensuite on enlèvera le robot
et ça peut du coup permettre de créer
des constructions très rapidement dans
des endroits où il ya de la migration de
personnes ou dans des endroits comme
l'afrique ou à les matériaux sont pas
tout à fait les mêmes
qu'est ce qu'on peut trouver ici donc ça
change complètement la façon de penser
urbanisme en attendant l'investissement
important d'un acteur du btp aucun
projet concret ne prévoit la création
d'un bâtiment 3d à usage réel
et regardez bien ce qu'il va suivre ça
va peut-être vous donner des idées de
sorties pouvoir pour votre week-end
c'est un grand nom de la gastronomie
française qui s'est installée à
versailles alain ducasse a ouvert il ya
une semaine sont vos restaurants aurait
au château de versailles des situé au
premier étage de l'ale dufour le
pavillon d'entrée du château de
versailles le lieu propose aux visiteurs
des classiques de la cuisine française
le soir après les visites il pourra être
privatisée et deviendra le théâtre de
grands dîners dans une mise en scène
évoquant le cérémonies royales une autre
façon de savourer versailles est une
fierté pour le chef étoilé étoilé pardon
je vous propose de l'écouter il nous
parle justement de la cuisine dès lors
et on s'est inspiré de ce que très
certainement
trois siècles plus tard en mangerait si
l'accord était encore en était encore en
compte d'ailleurs
et le soir on a réinterprété des dîners
royaux comme si le roi est hélas il
n'est pas là il mais il va arriver donc
c'est juste l'évolution de ce que
certainement on mangerait 6
la cour était encore en vie lyon
aujourd'hui et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve lundi pour un nouveau
journal je vous souhaite donc une
excellente soirée et un très bon week
end
[Musique]